hello so I have a New York film coming
out tomorrow it's called when I wanted
to die
it's something I made earlier this year
about February yes so it's eight months
old so anything that old in the YouTube
world you're like yeah I hate it but
there is one thing that I don't talk
about in that video that I think is
really important to address so 2017 was
undeniably like the best year of my life
I was in a relationship where I finally
thought like oh my god I found my person
I'm gonna marry this person I had
amazing friendships I had cultivated
after week years of searching for like
my tribe and my people and I was the
lead I'm the executive producer of youth
and consequences the show I did with you
to Brad and it was like a dream come
true and I left the cast and they loved
the script and I felt like this is what
I'm working towards like 10 years this
is like this dream job and so when my
depression also got the worst as it's
ever been in my entire life it felt so
weird I was like externally I have
everything I ever wanted and yet for the
first time I am now hearing voices or
one voice you know it's it's just this
one voice it was this one deep I would
say male voice that would randomly speak
up out of nowhere and say kill yourself
and I knew I was hearing voices because
it felt like it was in the room and I
felt like it was like this disembodied
thing but it was undeniably alone
wherever I was whenever I heard him in
the beginning and I didn't tell anyone
about it cuz I selfishly thought these
people care about me so much
if I tell people my depression so bad
that I'm hearing a voice I think they'll
hospitalized me and I won't get to live
my dream where they'll put me on
medication and I won't be present for
the dream the
and it was so hard because it was the
moment I realized like oh the problem is
me like everything is going perfect in
my life everything I ever wanted is
happening right now and yeah my brain is
gonna decide to like be the most
depressed it's ever been and give me a
fucking annoying voice that's gonna tell
me these terrible things so the problem
is me and um I did not tell anybody
about it for very long time I saw I just
kept it to myself
um and towards the end of last year I
was like you know what like I am a
hypocrite if I am constantly trying to
be a voice for mental health and for
mental illness and at the time I need
help
I'm refusing to get help then I'm a
hypocrite and so I talked to my
therapist about it
and he was like oh have you told anyone
about this and I was like no I'm just
kind of afraid I also am worried that
like like depression isn't glamorous you
know like dealing with someone who's
depressed is like annoying most of the
time I feel like for people around me
cuz it's like this is the disease people
don't get where you're like no I know I
should be happy no I know that logically
I know I should be fine but I'm not and
mine manifests itself in ways where I'm
not like lying on the floor and more
like I'm upset or I like feel a lot of
things manically or I'm like happy one
minute and I'm crying the next or I'm
overtly sensitive and so it's just like
all over the place mood wise it's just
that not a fun thing to live with for
people who are you know in my life and
he was like you know I feel like you
really should tell the people that you
love about this um and so I did I I was
about to tell my boyfriend when he got
back from this trip but before I could
he broke up with me and then the friends
that I had some shit happened and that
kind of like got put on pause and my
show didn't get renewed and it was
Christmas time which means there was no
work to do all my friends are out of
town I
wasn't on this trip I was supposed to go
with with my boyfriend and his family
and I was home all alone for like two or
three weeks and I got into a huge fight
with my mom and spent Christmas
completely alone and I had this two or
three weeks where I was totally isolated
and everything I thought I had was now
gone and that voice just got so intense
when I was by myself and for the first
time I would say like in my life I
seriously considered very logically okay
if I kill myself how am I gonna do it
what's gonna happen having been on the
other side I know like it's gonna
devastate my brother I know when my
parents are gonna be upset um I know my
friends will be hurt
who's gonna take care of my cats do I
need to write a will and um it got
really bad to where I had a plan and I
know from you know being in this space
like having a plan is like a major red
flag because the only next step then is
that person to follow the plan to kill
themselves and I managed to talk myself
out of it and be like no no no like this
will pass like just to you know don't be
a hypocrite like remember everything
you've ever said to people who wanted to
kill themselves like it's gonna pass
like yes it seems like it's forever
right now yes like fuck he or so I was
just showing pain and I just felt like I
had nothing like I was nobody and I
wasn't worth anything at all um I
literally like I have this big
whiteboard on my wall and I wrote out
like do not kill yourself like all
across it I put it on post-it notes and
I put it on my bathroom mirror and like
just every day when the voice came I was
just like shut the fuck up um and so I
mean I don't want to be hyperbolic and I
don't want to be overdramatic but really
this short that I made that comes out
tomorrow at 9:00 is sort of what I had
to live for um cuz at that moment it
felt like I didn't have anything to live
for and not gonna cry I'm not gonna cry
on a live stream
and uh yeah so I made a short come up
when I wanted to die and it highlights
everyone in my life I've sort of wanted
to die I mean I paired it down I'll be
six but um yeah it's really important to
me I look back on it now and because
it's eight months old like the short
segments old you're like anything's
better like this is to cheesier like
this is whatever but um no the doing
that short is honestly like I poured my
savings into it because I was like I
just need something to do that reminds
me of like why I'm here and like makes
me want to laugh because this is really
hard um and I just need to remember like
did you do something honestly just do
something so yeah that's what it is I
really hope you like it I hope I hope it
helps some of you who are maybe going
through now what I was going through
like eight nine months ago but yeah it's
I'm on the other side of it doing
depression and still a big old bitch but
I feel a lot better and I really took
care of myself at least in a way that
was healthy and I credit that you know
all the mental health education that's
available online and like doing the
things that you're supposed to do just
like every single day and hoping that
they add up and eventually they do you
just it takes a while to do it but yeah
um yeah that's what it is uh please
don't kill yourself if you are also
suicidal just don't do it
like there's a lot there's a lot of
great things to live for and now I'm
pleased to say you know I have really
great friends I'm still hunting for my
next dream job but it's all good and you
know I'm single but it's great because I
got cans
oh yeah life is a bunch of motherfuckin
ups and downs you just gotta pick right
outputs long waiting to get to that next
time ah yeah okay I hope you enjoy it
have a lovely day stay awesome Gotham